[Music]
hey guys adam here at north london
toyota just here to show you a quick
clip on what to do if your smart key
dies i've already taken the battery out
just to show you here
and our first step is going to be
finding the key
so if you look there closely there's a
little tab here and you'll just slide
that over
and you'll pull your key out from there
you'll unlock the car
and i'll show you that now so as you can
see we've got our key in our key fob and
just to show you the vehicle
is locked so we're going to take our key
we'll slide it at the keyhole here
turn it over we'll be able to get in the
car at this point
and then we'll hop in now once you're in
the vehicle you're gonna take your key
fob
and you're gonna put it right next to
the push to start
you put your foot on the brake
and start that up and now we're good to
go
so now you know what to do if your key
fob ever dies